President Biden's desperation is showing
again as he tries to pump up Democrats
before the midterms his party's chances
are dwindling by the day just as
Americans are about to get pummeled by
even higher gas prices so what is Joe's
solution a good old-fashioned bribe
President Biden treating our nation's
emergency oil stockpile as his own
personal piggy bank Biden is releasing
another 15 million barrels even though
our Reserve is at its lowest level in
nearly four decades and the best part
Biden isn't even being Coy about his
scheme
I have been doing everything in my power
to reduce gas prices since Putin's
invasion of Ukraine caused these price
hikes I've been acting so aggressively
without the steps we've taken over the
past several months to ramp up
production and lower prices and get
relief to Consumers bring down the price
you charge of the pump to reflect what
you pay for the product
you still make a significant profit your
shareholders will still do very well
and the American people will catch a
break they deserve and get a fair price
of the pump as well and seconds later
the same guy claimed that politics has
nothing to do with it
what is your response to Republicans who
say you are only doing this spr release
because to help Democrats in the
midterms where have they been the last
four months
that's my response is it politically
motivated sir no it's not three weeks
before the midterms look it makes it
makes sense with I've been doing this
for how long now
it's not politically motivated at all
okay so here we are the truth is that
gas went up 50 percent before the first
shot in the Ukraine and yet Biden uh is
making a decision that he's got to tap
the Strategic petroleum reserve the
lowest it's been in four decades
um why is he doing that he said because
he's been doing it for a long time
that's his answer
I like to go grocery shopping and really
I'll go and I'll buy lamb chops and I'll
stock up on dinners and I'll get home
sometimes and I'll I'll text them I'll
say so what what are we having for
dinner and she'll say Jesse you know
what sorry I got home late you're gonna
have to order delivery and I'm like we I
just went grocery shopping you're saying
now I have to order out that's Joe Biden
that is what he's doing I get it he is
he's not follow this analogy
his food delivery costs I've been eating
at him yeah
especially the ice cream so if you're
you're raining the rainy day fund and
it's not a rainy day he's been saying
we're going to have nuclear arm again
with Russia he's been saying China's
about to pray on Taiwan he's been saying
that climate change is making these
hurricanes more ferocious those are when
you want to use the rainy day fund not
when the Democrats are get to get rocked
this guy no wonder Hunter Biden handles
the finances and the money because he's
Reckless he's absolutely Reckless and
he's leaving the cupboards bear remember
when Trump came in during covid and he's
like the cupboards are bare there's no
PPE
that's because Obama and Biden left it
bare look what happened when Trump came
in he said military didn't have any
bullets that's what president Trump said
but we had to restock and now the same
thing's happening with oil and the same
thing judge is going to happen with our
armaments because we're giving it all to
the ukrainians it's very very
irresponsible and there's no
environmental difference right right
there's still going to be the same
emissions but American workers and
companies aren't going to get suffering
we paid for these stockpiles the
taxpayers now the taxpayers
aren't supposed to be taking a bath here
what are we going to do we're going to
sell the oil that we paid for to the
Chinese because Hunter has a connection
and then we're going to take the
revenues and then buy the IRS agent's
guns that doesn't make any sense
whatsoever Joe Biden knows it but that's
all he has left the truth is Piers that
uh you know when Joe Biden talked about
this he said that you know it that that
the big oil companies they they're
making more money than ever which isn't
true uh but that they should share the
profits and you know what Jesse when you
talked about Hunter don't you think
Hunter should share some of the profits
maybe 10 for the big guy you know
um you know the whole thing is
anti-capitalists yeah I mean I think the
thing about uh President Biden it's
never his fault anything is the one
thing that I've really noticed from his
presidency it's always somebody else's
fault usually he blames Putin or whoever
he can think of but actually here if you
chart the Genesis of his relationship
with parties for example when he was
running for president he was very vocal
the Saudis had to become pariahs exactly
I'm sure that didn't go down well with
Saudi who of course considered
themselves to be an ally of the United
States then of course he's been flirting
again with the Iranians that again will
not go down well with the Saudis so
surprise surprise the Saudis are not
overly Keen to help him out in his
moment of need about oil prices and
they've decided to cut production and
Joe Biden is throwing his toys out of a
stroller about it well you reap what you
sow to an extent so I think constantly
blaming other people which seems to be
his his default mechanism for anything
which actually could be laid at his door
I think he's beginning to wear a bit
thin with the electorate and of course
this is transparent transparently
political you know this is done to try
and correct what's going on at the gas
prices where he saw a little blip up in
the Democrat fortunes heading to the
midterms but now gas prices are edging
back up again not falling he wants to
try and stop it so it's it's all very
disingenuous very political and by
blaming Putin again very Biden
#all right you know Dana the truth is
that you know if he releases the 15
million barrels I mean it is that's not
going to happen
it's just about one day's worth and it's
a global market we have if you believe
in markets a global market for it was
what we have and so that's what helps
set the price that's why you need to
have more that's why you should be
producing more energy here in America I
think a lot of people are still confused
about why on day one is first order of
business was it cancel the Keystone
Pipeline and then you had them pass the
inflation reduction act which was really
the climate change build look at all of
the green groups on the left when that
bill passed they were thrilled because
they got everything that they were
promised and what happened is you had
the president opposing domestic energy
trying to force a transition on the
country that we're just just not ready
for not because we don't want it but
we're just not quite there in the
Innovation the Innovations will come and
are exciting and there's a lot of good
stuff down the pipeline but we're not
going to get to what President Biden
wants which is carbon neutral by 2050.
if you actually want to do that that
comes with a price and the price is what
you're seeing now this is a fraction of
the price of what you would have to pay
and then you had the president raise
taxes on everybody in order to give rich
people tax breaks so they could buy
electric vehicles it cost eighty
thousand dollars
all right
the truth is that the president stood
there today Greg and he demanded that
those oil companies ramp up production
while he tied their hands well you know
Joe Biden is such an incompetent leader
even his bribes suck I mean if you're
gonna if you're going to bribe us you
know do give us something great he said
that he's saving 420 million dollars a
day Americans are because of what he's
been doing so there are 360 million
Americans I did the math otherwise known
as fractions Dana came to an average of
a dollar 30 per American so how do you
break even under the Biden economy when
every average American or the average
American has lost thirty four thousand
dollars you know I did the math again uh
because I know I know yes uh it'll take
30 000 days to break even that's 90
years 90 years to get back the money you
lost with this stupid bribe anyway you
got to go back to that fatal mistake
that the the Democrats made which is
what they treat kitchen table issues
like a joke and they treated a joke
which is the virtue signaling woke stuff
as something serious and so everything
went upside down and we called this we
call this the perfect example when the
kids were in lockdown and the San
Francisco School Board were busy
changing the names of schools they were
voting on it and then what happened to
them we LED with it they were recalled
and I remember we were saying this is
going to spread because it and and it's
funny it's like maybe Obama is the only
Democrat that watches this show because
he obviously figured it out but nobody
else did if they had listened to us when
that happened was that like a year ago
they wouldn't be in this mess anyway
that's my theory all right good theory
it's good one hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else